sure the margin for error is time yeah
it's getting uh you are have to be more
precise and eventually probably maybe
after instead of f14 was only
yeah
if it was i'm not sure anymore
but i think this imagination hits the
nail on the head
it's i mean you're tempted to say that
first cracks but that it's like okay you
made one simple mistake but it's not
like that it's indeed as you say this
seeing
all the possibilities where can he go
wrong
fascinating
yeah and psychologically it's hard for
fruzo when he knows okay it was a two
result game for the whole time despite
the fact he should make a draw and
knowing that suddenly he needed to be
super accurate when that pressure wasn't
on before
okay meanwhile
a few moves have been made white's
bishop has tied down the black bishop to
his pawn and
at the right moment where i can just
push a6 maybe that moment is now
okay no not yet no rush
but after bishop e4 and bishop moves
away then a6
yeah and actually she does awesome
resigns
there we go
i have a feeling that you'll have a
similar smile on magnus's face because
he knows that well maybe not
he'll save that smile for us maybe
he'll be very happy